Now even scientists have a hard time counting chromosomes that
are just disorganized like this. We know now that there are
46 chromosomes in here somewhere, but obviously trying to see
which one is which can be difficult. So what we want
to do is what scientists do, which is try to
find them and line them up in order of biggest to
smallest. And I'm actually going to give you a little taste of
that here. And I'm actually going to try to organize them
by literally cutting and pasting them one-by-one.
[NOISE]
Okay, so this was my very amateur job at trying
to organize these chromosomes in order, from biggest to smallest. You
can see it, there's some imperfections here. I probably didn't
get it right, because this isn't my job. This isn't something
I do on a regular basis. Well let's take a
look at how scientists actually would put them in a row.
Okay, so, here's what it looks like if a professional
scientist, who works with chromosomes and knows what they're doing here,
if they cut and paste them and organize them. they'll
get ordered in this way. So i want you to pay
really close attention to all the chromosomes that you see here
and see if there's any kind of pattern that stands out
to you. What I want you to tell me is if
you see nay pattern that stands out in all of these
chromosomes when they're ordered in this fashion from biggest to smallest.
Try to think of an answer, one or two word response
if possible, and put it in the text box here.
Don't worry so much about getting this question right or
wrong. Just try to look for any pattern that you
see, and then put it in the text box here.